ah bonjour michel five merci d'être avec
nous ce matin alors nouvel échec dans la
constitution d'un gouvernement au liban
c'est aussi l'échec des relations entre
le premier ministre hariri et le
président aoun qu'est ce qui ne marche
pas entre les deux hommes bonjour tout
d'abord oui ceux qui marchent pas entre
les deux hommes c'est plusieurs éléments
et en fait ça va rires et cherche à
nommer différents ministres au sein du
gouvernement il avait cherché à nommer
le ministre des affaires étrangères pour
pouvoir se réconcilier avec l'arabie
saoudite
ils cherchent à contrôler le ministère
de l'intérieur pour contrôler les
prochaines élections
ils cherchent à contrôler le ministère
de la justice pour contrôler les
prochaines arrestations et ils cherchent
à contrôler le ministère des finances
avec le président du parlement pour
contrôler l'audit juricomptable exigés
par le fmi et la communauté
internationale à cela il a même voulu
carrément nommer tous les ministres en
contradiction totale avec la
constitution libanaise qui prévoit la
formation du gouvernement par le
président de la république et le premier
ministre désigné
cela en fait afin de maintenir un réel
partenariat entre chrétiens et musulmans
alors que ces derniers jours et
souhaitait même et cervières semaine il
souhaitait faire un espèce de
gouvernement de trois tiers avec un
tiers des ministres nommés par lui un
tiers des ministres nommés par le camp
chiite amal et hezbollah et un tiers
nommé par le président de la république
christian est en fait tout ça même à
sauter il a présenté une liste 24
ministres qui est qui lui choisit ses
seuls peut-être simplement le ministre
des finances était le fruit de la corde
entre lui et ministre et le président du
parlement cheikh mai mais voilà il a
essayé en fait de limiter le rôle du
président de la république à une simple
signature du décret ça fait longtemps
que la crise politique aussi a commencé
au liban presque un an maintenant sans
eau sans gouvernement
on se demande si si le liban va
reconnaître un gouvernement un jour si
c'est possible de créer un gouvernement
au liban c'est aussi votre sentiment
oui en fait aujourd'hui tout l'enjeu est
là est ce qu'il y aura un gouvernement
avant les élections législatives prévues
en mai 2022
maintenant ce que ce vers quoi on
s'oriente ça c'était peut être un
gouvernement qui serait en charge de
préparer les élections avec un premier
ministre et des ministres qui ne
seraient pas eux mêmes candidats aux
prochaines élections
vous parliez des élections législatives
la politiquement dans les jours dans les
semaines à venir que va-t-il se passer
chaque parti politique et des gens
campagne électorale donc vous voyez sur
le terrain les différents partis qui
essaye d'apporter une certaine aide
sociale pour en fait pour créer du
clientélisme afin que les les différents
et enfin les électeurs votent pour eux
parce que ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
la livre libanaise s'est effondré il
fallait 1500 livres libanaises pour
faire un dollar jusqu en octobre 2019
aujourd'hui il en faut 22 me on parle de
77% de libanais qui n'arriveraient pas à
manger à leur faim dont 33 pour cent des
enfants
donc c'est ça la réalité sur le terrain
et du coup quand un parti politique vous
offre un port un peu d'argent vous fait
acheter en fait alors les etats-unis
parlent de déception à la france
d'autodestruction cynique
l'onu appelle les dirigeants libanais à
former un nouveau gouvernement au plus
vite l emmo sont assez forts 1 mais
visiblement les pressions des autres
pays
monsieur ne suffisent plus pour le liban
oui
simplement c'est un peu facile de dire
que c'est la faute que des libanais et
pas la faute des puissances
internationales parce que les puissances
étrangères ont donné un appui quasi
inconditionnel à saad hariri a par
l'arabie saoudite
mais cet appui inconditionnel en fait
avec cet appui cellules capables et de
faire tout ce qu'il voulait alors que il
ce qu'il faut pas oublier c'est qu'en
octobre 2019
les manifestants avaient obtenu sa
démission
c'était l'une des principales exigences
et rappelons-nous aussi que ce sont les
ailes et que les manifestations étaient
vraiment très importante dans les trois
grandes villes ce une qui sont à
majorité sunnite au liban c'est à dire
beyrouth tripoli et saïda donc il était
vraiment très contestée et en fait il ya
un certain qu'en politique au liban qui
est qu'on appelle le camp du parti des
banques qui étaient en fait
avery le président du parlement nabih
berry jean blatt
le leader druze associé au hezbollah qui
se sont en fait liés pour le faire
ramener au poste de premier ministre et
de là les américains les français les
russes les émirati les égyptiens l'ont
soutenu et lui en fait a cru pouvoir
imposer un gouvernement seuls en dehors
qui ne respecte pas la constitution
merci à michel fayard d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin sur arte france rappelle
que vous êtes analyste politique et
financier et merci beaucoup